[Music]
all right you guys are all familiar with
uh leah thomas right who's leah familiar
who is leah thomas is the 22 year old
transgender swimmer that's been
competing um oh stanford
is that stanford yeah competing in the
women's in the women's division whooping
ass she's like six two bro yeah by like
annihilating records beating the
[ __ ] out of the other channel because
the weightlifter went to the olympics uh
bombed out oh [ __ ] yeah yeah it was
aussie right yeah
this one's like
this one's like like 30 40 seconds ahead
of second place right like she's like
laughing she's like damn you're laughing
what's the guy in girls time in general
are the guys that far ahead i do know
that i mean because like marathon it's
not it's a crazy-ass thing but um so
recently leah thomas is now the champion
of the ncaa
women's
if in the men's
i think i read that
um
leah thomas's place if it were the men's
league would be like 550 something wow
so dang that's the difference something
in this particular event race
because it's so like event by event it's
a lot of it like in swimming it is more
advantageous you have longer limbs
taller so then but like like like a
world record like like 100 meter
gotta grow is a huge gap but the
marathon is like a pretty small gap and
then what like the ultra ultra crazy
marathon a lady won
yeah so like it's so sport-dependent
yeah so sport-dependent for event
department in general most sports it's
dudes dogs are definitely the best yeah
yeah you're right you're right
like generally speaking yeah yeah
they don't have these yet
you're definitely right bro
yeah
[Laughter]
it's like what you're saying is dudes
are pretty cool
i think you got a dick like this one
this was a pretty crazy situation
because i mean everyone's been kind of
following how this is going
but now that it's the championship
uh
leah thomas was finishing that last
uh run
everybody was like a lot of people were
booing
and then once the second place person
was fishing everyone started cheering do
we know uh and this might be digging a
little too deep i've done a couple
interviews and a couple of things down
this path with sports yeah and um do we
know the rules they follow because
wada's rules are like something weird
it's like three years of surgery and a
certain amount of hormone therapy and
you're in yeah leah thomas did do the
hormone therapy that was required to
compete in this way but then they
changed the rules i think during yeah so
it doesn't apply to leah thomas
but it will apply to the next did she
because i also read that like
she was a delaying some of the
hormonal therapy that would have slowed
her down
uh oh that's interesting and i'm like oh
i don't know that's so like technical
it's like reverse uh steroids yeah yeah
i know it is yeah it is
but yeah it's yeah it almost sounds like
people are cheering for the second place
that's like the people's choice first
place
right yeah that's people's channel
that sounds like johnson if they're
saying like boo and they're like yay
even even leah thomas's own teammates
are speaking out against one goggle
because leah's smoking them well i think
dude this is such a hard time
[Laughter]
i have so many solutions i really do
well i don't know if i have answers but
like yeah they don't take into account a
lot of different things that are
different between
biological males and females um
something called the q angle which is
where our hips and knees line up
that naturally make sometimes dudes will
propel forward a little bit faster like
running and i don't know much about
swimming uh
lately like the big thing with that is
literally ladies hips are just wider out
than their knees tons of ladies rip acls
a lot more than guys just because that
sideways pressure um they're just like
less hydrodynamic i don't know about
swimming yeah i don't know about
swimming but it's definitely possible
there are conversations like lung
capacity stuff like that that come into
play
ligaments tendons uh even like i don't
necessarily know because hormone range
um
with
people is is so vast that's why like if
you've ever gotten your blood tested
like the natural guy range is like 200
milligrams to like 800. and all of
that's considered normal it's all normal
right
testosterone yeah it's insane yeah what
i do know is some of the rules with
water or or
that's why
is world anti-doping agency that's not
what bruce lee says
[Music]
[Laughter]
they set the rules for the olympics et
cetera et cetera they the rules they set
for transgender competition
were set in such a certain way that i
believe uh uh what's the proper term i
don't mean to insult nobody biologically
born woman in jamaica or maybe nigeria
or somewhere couldn't compete because
she didn't match these new set of like
hormone rules oh cause she's she had
high tests right or something
yeah and so she she was supposed to be
in these last olympics and she couldn't
naturally
because of these because a lot of it
they're just basically it seems like a
surface level base because they're
basing it all on hormones in time which
isn't a thing it's so weird because the
whole point of sports
is to let the outliers shine yeah sure
that's the whole point like even with
like you saying bolt right like the
average field the air the average 100
meter sprinter like the ideal body for a
short distance sprint is someone between
5 10 6 feet because that's i think the
most optimal like big pecks where's
green
because sprint is all about how quickly
you pick up speed right but usain bolt i
think they did like an anatomy
examination and where his femur is
attached he technically he's like 6'4 so
he should be too slow he might even be
six six he's a monster so that's like
almost like starting a sprint on the
highest gear on like a mountain bike but
because of where it's attached he can
actually accelerate like a 510 guy but
then once he hits top speed he has the
sixth gear because of his height so like
the whole point of sports is to distill
the outliers right yeah michael phelps
has said some of the things like he's
got some [ __ ] web toes and you know
his dicks like a fin or something i
don't know
that's the whole point of sports
is to find the outliers but it sucks
that that lady
couldn't compete yeah it's just all
weird because there are there's so many
factors that go into it and so like i
don't know how if i can like word this
correctly but will the outlier
of a natural-born woman
that gap between like the most athletic
woman and like the least athletic man
and then they're like the most athletic
and least athletic trans gender like
what does that spectrum look like yeah
where does it sit we don't have enough
data we have no clue yeah because
there's so many other there's even like
exposure is a huge factor like you could
be the best
swimmer ever and you never touch water
we just don't know because you haven't
been exposed to that sport
right so like our data is incomplete on
all of this and so they make the rules
just based on purely hormones because
that's one thing you just blood test oh
we got hormones i think because there's
two conversations going on right one is
like trying to redefine um what these
categories of gender
is right and should be which is like a
societal conversation maybe yeah and
then the other part is now we have the
scientific one because if you don't have
an objective description of what this
thing is like what is this thing like is
it male is it female is it what is this
being even in animals how do you
describe and what do you label this as
in like for example if we if if we get
in a car crash right and we die or
whatever you have to still figure out
well uh i got to treat maybe this male
different from female so what is it
right and then and then the people that
maybe come from the non-binary
genderless camp might be like well we're
all the same but it's like okay fine
society-wise
maybe right everyone should get the
respect fine fine we let's figure out
different names and rules for that but
we still need
some type of identifiers for the
differences in science and i think
that's basically the two conversations
that kind of conflict because one is a
social definition or like what is the
fair kind way of doing it or
or there's gender roles attached with
the definition of i mean with the with
the with the label of gender like males
this and that i'm like that's a
different conversation but now we put it
in athletics right and they're like
everyone should be able to compete fine
let's take the genderless approach of
everyone competes it's co it's co-ed
whatever what's going to end up
happening is the elite of the elite is
going to be the only ones that compete
at a high level then it's going to be
discrimination because then it's not
going to be inclusive toward everyone
that maybe want to compete right yeah
but at the highest level it should be
that way yeah i think i did you're 100
because
and i'd probably agree like from my own
belief and whatever the truth may be is
like gender and all these things they
are
fluid in spectrums sports aren't
so how do we combine them sports are
made to be rigid binary rules basketball
you can't dribble with two hands
yes no no you're not allowed to so like
how do we morph those whether it be
maybe sports need to go more societal or
maybe sports need to stay where they are
i don't know i don't have the answer but
that's you're right that's where it gets
[ __ ] complicated on like like for
elementary school right you want a co-ed
group where everyone gets to play right
but on a high
competitive level like the olympics or
maybe professional sports you want the
best of the best right and it's like am
i going to be like oh man the nba is so
racist because like they'll never let a
five-two asian guy play
but it's like that is racist
it's like well they want the team that's
gonna win so they want all these seven
foot dudes to be in team and it's like
duh right but are they short phobic like
i don't know
i think that's what it really is the nba
short phobic dude well i guess i guess
for that same reason that it's like
regardless of the gender it's like uh if
i was a coach of a female swimming team
i bet oh that's a woman now bring her on
my team because i need my team to win
right
so it's like i
i think back to like his concept of like
binary rules versus like social
conversation and time frame uh it's
funny because sports is one of those
things where it's like this very like
all-inclusive thing right you'll see
like nations compete against each other
that normally are bickering and during
wartime and stuff but you can come
together for sports so there is this
social conversation that does exist
there but then it's like when you're
talking about a a gender separated like
league or or denominations like this is
men's basketball women's vol you know
what i mean then it's like the second
transgender comes into there it's like
that's definitely flirting with like a
difference of of what the kind of
segregation of genders was in the
beginning to be able to create rules for
you know what i'm saying so it's
difficult it's such a new concept too
yeah so it's also gonna like we're in
the icing the stone age of this like
being a topic so
it's and how many other transgender
athletes
do we even hear about those are like the
three huge ones right fallon fox yeah
the ufc chick or mma jake uh the
weightlifter i can't remember her name
and then this one i think those are like
the three wasn't there some wrestlers
that were college collegiate wrestlers
that was crushing it but i think that's
crazy because like imagine like put
yourself in the future like 100 years
from now looking back on all of the
[ __ ] stats of like the records for
like everything and if those stats are
still separated by like men and women
but it's like the number one in all
these women categories is like a
transgender like form you know what i
mean it's kind of like what hopefully
what does that mean and also what
direction are they going and like are
they going in the direction of more
rules
or more categories or less categories so
like this the nigerian chick right that
has above uh yeah the accepted level of
testosterone even though it's natural
then the next category that makes me
think is okay even if it's like two
males or two females then is there a
iq range yeah right because that plays
into sports like crazy oh [ __ ] right
like chord iq right like you have a guy
that's like oh wait this guy's way too
[ __ ] smart he breaks plays down like
this then they're like then so are
people competing in weight classes and
iq and hormone levels and age how much
do you want to go too stupid when you
guys will know but it's like a future
euphoric world and they they make
everybody even that way so if my legs
are stronger then i have gotta cut the
movie no it's maybe it's based on the
book though people know dude it's like a
[ __ ] stupid famous book i think and
and i have to i'd have to have ankle
weights on and if you're super smart or
something like you have like electric
shock hit your brain every 15 seconds to
slow you down to be on my level like
[ __ ] like that it evens everybody to the
same [ __ ] kind of like you're talking
about in a way i write that's kind of
crazy less rules and see what happens
yeah yeah i mean even it like uh street
racing and car car racing obviously
there's cars that are just going to beat
all of them but they make them gap
they go okay you're going to start way
up here sure this guy's going to start
way back here legal street racing right
yeah yeah
that's pretty good that's funny because
even the illegal ones do it that way
everyone listens to vin diesel illegal
cats got rules they're so progressive
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you